et en face à face ce soir avec bruno
m'égare ban chef de service de
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière
bonsoir à vos côtés philippe froguel
généticien bonsoir alors bruno m'égare
manière vous avez cosigné une tribune
dans le jdd vous appelé le gouvernement
à prendre des mesures beaucoup plus
radicales et vous mettez en garde je
cite contre une deuxième vague bien plus
difficile à gérer pour les hôpitaux et
les services de réanimation que la
première alors est-ce qu'on revient
réellement à une situation proche de
mars dernier
alors tout d'abord merci beaucoup alors
non nous n'avons pas interpeller le
gouvernement mais nous avons souhaité
alerter la population sur la situation
et expliquer les raisons pour lesquelles
nous nous trouvons désormais en
possibles difficultés
effectivement depuis maintenant quelques
semaines le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations augmente de façon
significative et malheureusement
maintenant depuis une dizaine de jours
le nombre d'admissions à l'hôpital est
en réanimation de cas plus graves de
lakovic 19 augmente avec dans certaines
grandes métropoles comme à marseille une
saturation du nombre de lits qui avait
été réservée pour la prise en charge de
ces patients
la situation à paris devient également
relativement alarmante puisque
aujourd'hui par exemple près de 175 lits
sur 502 capacitaire de réanimation
médicale et chirurgicale à l'assistance
publique des hôpitaux de paris est
occupée par des patients présentant la
copie 19 en fait l'alertent avait pour
but d'inciter les citoyens à plus de
prudence et notamment une meilleure
application des mesures barrières et du
port du masque lorsque celui ci est
nécessaire
principalement pendant les réunions
familiales élargie ou amicales philippe
froguel le confinement que l'on pensait
un dernière nous
est ce que c'est aujourd'hui clairement
une perspective à remettre sur la table
le continent on voit bien dans plusieurs
pays que ça peut revenir on la vit en
espagne on voit dans d'autres pays
c'est même envisagé à berlin 1 par
madame merkel ça ça nous c'est quelque
chose qui est devant nous si
effectivement comme le craignent un
certain nombre de collègues on arrive à
une saturation à des animations et des
guides et urgence puisque rappelons
quand même en mars et cette saturation
qui a amené le premier confinement la
vraie question c'est est-ce que vraiment
on va jusqu'à là et c est ce que les ce
genre de tribunes ciblant uniquement la
population des trucs et utile
personnellement moi je suis contre ces
tribunes je pense que les médecins les
savants sont ne sont pas là pour
morigéner la population ils sont là pour
analyser le real ce qui se passe et ça
ça a été fait je comprends très bien ils
sont hérisson là pour proposer des
solutions pas simplement de dire le
montrer des rôles de figurants dix ans
avec dédé courbe exponentielle que le 15
novembre sera saturé personne n'en sait
strictement rien par contre ce qui me
semble important c'est de conseiller le
gouvernement
comment faire mieux et ça c'était pas
dans les tribunes récente et je trouve
que on se trouve un peu de cibles
aujourd'hui même si effectivement il
faut rajouter vos dires la population de
faire attention à ça c'est évident bruno
megaman qu'est ce que vous répondez à
philippe froguel
qui vous dit à l'instant ce n'est pas il
ne faut pas à la s'adresser à la
population aujourd'hui il ne faut pas
les culpabiliser ou font aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez non à
nouveau notre propos n'étaient pas du
tout de culpabiliser quiconque
on va dire la situation est difficile
l'application des mesures barrière n'est
pas facile porter le masque n'est pas
évident simplement ce sont des conseils
que nous prodiguons effectivement nous
sommes tous acteurs et nous devons être
responsables car la circulation du virus
se fait par nous même si le virus ne
circule pas si nous-mêmes nous ne
faisons pas circuler
le problème ici c'est que le virus
malheureusement
et traître c'est à dire en fait les
personnes qui le portent sont pour les
trois quarts d'entre elles
asymptomatique et donc ne savent pas
qu'elles vont malheureusement favoriser
sa circulation et contaminer d'autres
personnes
et puis malheureusement parmi ces
personnes il peut se trouver des
personnes plus âgées plus à risque de
faire des formes graves
c'est là la difficulté le deuxième
problème essentiel c'est qu'il existe un
délai d'une quinzaine de jours entre la
contamination et l'expression de la
maladie est là aussi et c'est pourquoi
nous souhaitions attirer l'attention sur
la situation épidémiologique tous que le
nôtre l'on observe actuellement reflète
ce qui s'est passé il ya quinze jours
or depuis les contaminations augmenter
de façon importante et en fait dans 15
jours nous sommes inquiets effectivement
sur le risque que ces patients affectés
soient encore plus nombreux à l'hôpital
et qu'il de fait en raison bien sûr et
c'est là le problème de base en raison
du nombre limité de lits de réanimation
à disposition qu'il puisse altérer
l'offre de soins et que malheureusement
on soit obligé de reporter ou de
déprogrammer un certain nombre
d'activités chirurgicales non urgentes
ou d'activités médicales utile pour les
patients porteurs de maladies chroniques
alors malheureusement je n'ai pas de
communication directe avec le
gouvernement pour lui donner le moindre
conseil
d'ailleurs je ne me permettrais pas le
gouvernement est très probablement
entouré de personnes encore plus savante
que moi et encore plus expertes du sujet
je nous avons tout simplement souhaité
exprimer une opinion à nouveau qui n'a
qui n'a aucun but moralisateur mais
simplement d'information de la
population
il est temps évidemment que tout le
monde puisse comprendre et prendre sa
responsabilité
on fait appel au sens civique de chacun
d'entre nous philippe froguel vous
entendez bruno mega man qui nous dit au
fond et c'est vrai que nous sommes tous
concernés par l'évolution de cette
épidémie
oui mais entendu mais la peur n'évite
pas le danger
et j'ai un peu peur que par contre cette
tribune enfonce un peu des portes
ouvertes
en disant qu'il faut porter le masque
oui effectivement il faut porter le
masque et qu'il faut faire attention au
café et le porter réellement quand on a
pas on n'est pas en train de boire
justement sa tasse de café certes c'est
tout à fait mais si c'était suffisant on
n'aurait pas 13 me de compte personne
contaminée aujourd'hui et le masque
c'est un retardateur c'est un petit peu
comme dans un fait un feu de forêt dans
les canadairs lance des des liquides sur
la forêt
s'il n'ya pas en bas et les pompiers le
feu s'arrête pas et on l'a bien vu
peut-être qu'on aurait cent mille tombes
contaminés par jour sans les masques
mais ça empêche pas de cette
augmentation donc il ya des choses qui
ne vont pas et ça c'est la chose
importante à faire et qui n'est pas
proposée moi personnellement je pense
que le le gros trous dans la raquette
qu'on a depuis le début c'est le test
à voir aujourd'hui dans la ville de
paris d'un test en 18 jours c'est ce un
de mes copains m'a dit ça aujourd'hui
c'est inacceptable c'est totalement
inacceptable parce que ça sert à rien de
faire des tests en dépense énormément
d'argent pour plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros pour des tests qui ne
servent à rien aujourd'hui alors que ce
qu'il faut c'est monté des plateformes
pour faire des tests et des résultats en
une journée
là ça serait efficace bruno mégarde un
effectivement ce qu'on vient d'entendre
les propos de philippe froguel
est ce que votre tribune justement votre
signal d'alarmé d'un ce n'est pas la
preuve que la stratégie du gouvernement
a raté on parlait des tests un récemment
on a testé tester tester mais
visiblement le triptyque protéger tester
isolé n'a pas vraiment fonctionné alors
j'irai je suis d'accord avec les propos
du professeur froguel
donc effectivement les tests sauf que
c'est quelque chose de très important à
mon avis simplement il ne faut pas les
opposer au masque c'est complémentaire
et effectivement je ne peux pas dire que
la stratégie actuellement utilisé des
tests est optimale maintenant je ne
jetterai pas la pierre au ministre de la
santé non plus je crois qu'il fait au
mieux du possible
malgré tout il faut effectivement et là
je suis d'accord il faut optimiser les
tests en priorisant en introduisant là
où c'est possible
les nouveaux tests antigénique et
salivaires pour permettre évident a
effectivement que ces tests soient
complémentaires au mieux pour le masquer
mais malgré tout je ré insiste
effectivement le port du masque reste la
clé en fait si on portait de façon
satisfaisante le masque dans les bonnes
circonstances
eh bien on aurait aucune raison d'être
contaminés et donc aucune raison de
devoir faire des tests le problème c'est
que les gens malheureusement porte
relativement bien le masque dans les
supermarchés dans les moyens de
transport dans la rue la houle intérêts
beaucoup plus limité et finalement
rentrer chez eux assistent à des soirées
entre amis ou des réunions familiales et
là comme par hasard en confiance parce
qu'effectivement ils sont avec des
personnes qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement enlève le masque et
risquent malheureusement de se
contaminer
c'est effectivement ces fameuses soirées
entre amis qu'il faut dans la mesure du
possible reporter et si elles doivent
être absolument organiser et bien il
maintenir la distanciation social où il
portait le masque notamment en présence
d'une personne plus âgée ou un risque
philippe royal avant de conclure
l'espoir viendra peut-être finalement du
nord puisqu'il ya du nouveau à
l'institut pasteur de lille est sur la
piste d'un médicament pour début 2010 21
qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
philippe froguel
alors nous a lille on va faire deux
choses sur les tests on va ouvrir début
octobre une grande plate-forme qui fera
au minimum dix mille tests par jour en
moins de 24 heures on ne va ouvrir le
zénith de lille pour ça donc ça ça va
être une grande première qu'on espère
pouvoir faire partout en france avec des
partenaires privés des laboratoires
privés et deuxièmement effectivement mon
collègue à benoît déprez à un travail
qui a débuté vraiment très très tôt à 1
dès le mois de mars à trouver une
molécule qui est une molécule connue qui
est vendu déjà pour deux autres choses
qui
a eu d'effets secondaires que nous même
pas de contenu et ce médicament qui est
générique et et bien dans les études
cellulaire ce qu'on appelle et in vitro
et beaucoup beaucoup plus efficace à des
doses faibles que la fameuse hydroxy
chloroquine marseillaise alors on en est
là et on essaie aujourd'hui de débiter
des études cliniques qui ne sont pas
faciles on l'a vu pour les tests
salivaires ça a été extrêmement
difficile de faire ses études sur les
tests salivaires qui sont pas encore
complètement terminé
et là on espère pour avoir ça dans les
dents les prochains mois et on espère
qu'il y aura une aide du gouvernement
mais aussi de nos collègues cliniciens
pour qu'on puisse tester ce médicament à
la seconde je suis incapable de vous
dire s'il sera efficace médicalement il
ya loin de la coupe aux lèvres
comme vous pouvez vous en douter et
deuxièmement donnera pas le nom parce
que il ya eu l'expérience très
malheureuse de l'hydroxyde c'est entendu
un grand merci en tout cas philippe
froguel je rappelle que vous êtes
généticien merci à vous bruno megaman
chef du service de réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière